i
[Música]
a
nueva york- comienza ya su navidad con
el iluminado del árbol más famoso del
mundo el del rockefeller center este año
no contará con la visita de los más de
750 mil turistas diarios que lo
visitaron en el 2019 pero sí que
mantendrá su elegancia cerca de 50 mil
luces ledley adornarán y en lo alto
volveremos a ver esa estrella diseñada
en el 2018 y formada por cerca de 3
millones de cristales swarovski este año
los famosos escaparates de los grandes
almacenes macys estarán dedicados a los
trabajadores esenciales y a los médicos
por su lucha contra el kobe 19
preocupados están los comerciantes a ver
cómo se desarrollan estas navidades a
nivel económico porque para que se hagan
una idea si el año pasado 69 millones de
turistas visitaron la gran manzana este
año no llega ni a los 30 millones
[Música]
el encendido de las luces de navidad de
los campos elíseos se produjo cuando
este país todavía estaba confinado el
90% de los comerciantes de esta lujosa
avenida estaba cerrado pero pese a ello
los organizadores que son los propios
comerciantes decidieron mantener la
ceremonia pues para ellos representa el
puntapié inicial de las fiestas de fin
de año en las que esperan reponerse al
fin de la crisis económica derivada del
cobi 19 la ceremonia en sí fue muy
discreta una treintena de personas entre
ellos la alcaldesa de parís encendieron
las luces desde un balcón en los campos
del icio sin embargo la mayoría de las
personas siguieron la ceremonia a través
de la televisión y pudieron participar
de manera virtual encendiendo una de las
bombillas a través de internet y esto se
vio muy lindo en la transmisión pues
aparecían los nombres de las personas
como un holograma saliendo de estos 400
plátanos orientales decorados en rojo
esta operación de encendido de las
luminarias que durante siete semanas
decora los campos elíseos cuesta 800 mil
euros que son pagados por los
comerciantes pero sobre todo por la
marca de comida italiana ferrero un
sponsor muy polémico pues está acusado
de deforestar en asia para producir
aceite de palma y de fomentar la
obesidad infantil con sus productos
[Música]
los moscovitas se están preparando para
una temporada navideña poco convencional
después de la cancelación de las
festividades anuales de navidad y año
nuevo en la ciudad y el cierre del
entretenimiento nocturno y las nuevas
restricciones en cines y teatros han
empañado mucho estas fiestas a pesar de
todas estas restricciones
moscú ya está colocando luces extra en
toda la ciudad invitando a los
residentes a disfrutar de un paseo
festivo por la ciudad casi la única
forma de entretenerse guardando la
distancia de seguridad y a cielo abierto
una peculiaridad de moscú es que para
hacer más llevadero el invierno hace
años que las luces de navidad al menos
parte de ellas están puestas durante
prácticamente todo el año son en todo
caso unas navidades más aburridas porque
los clubes las discotecas y los bares
cierran a las 11 de la noche
[Música]